after years of waiting the super light 2
is finally here thing is it looks nearly
identical to the original now look there
have definitely been some improvements
under the hood but has Logitech done
enough for anyone to actually go out and
buy one these are the same mushy side
buttons that the GPX launched with which
is kind of sad I just don't think that
there is enough Blaze trailing going on
here to really justify this as A2 but
when it comes to the stock skates
there's still absolute docs sounds kind
of grim but let's find out together is
the soup
upgrade we've all been waiting for
a waste of money
all right so we've already made videos
about the original g-pro and more
recently we talked about logitech's
decision to not Implement 4K polling
rates into their new mouse but today we
are bringing you a proper review of the
super light 2. once again Logitech
claims they worked with over a hundred
Pros to ensure that their new mouse is
worthy of being used on esports's
biggest stages but a lot of you have
been asking what they actually changed
with the new model because from the
outside looking in
it doesn't look like much the shape is
the same as the original G Pro and the
first super light which makes sense
because it's always been known as one of
the safest shapes among all gaming mice
Logitech designed their mice hoping that
99 of people could just pick one up and
have a good time and for that very
reason I don't think a ton of people
expected the super light 2 to look or
feel very different from its predecessor
but inside the mouse there have
definitely been a few changes Logitech
reduced the weight just a measly three
grams mind you and added new hybrid
Optical mechanical switches when you set
them to hybrid mode they only make use
of the optical feature when you click
down on Mouse 1 and 2 which conserves
battery life when it's not in use and
since the new switches are Optical
hopefully you won't have any double
clicking issues as for the sensor
Logitech has upgraded to the Hero 2
which allows you to set your DPI to more
precise increments and change the X and
Y axes now they say that this could be
useful for refined the sensitivity of
vertical spray control in games like CS
but I don't really think it's something
I would ever use but one of the more
controversial changes is to the bottom
Mouse skate Logitech has gone with a new
design that points slightly outwards
from the mouse rather than inwards like
the original super light in theory these
new zero additive PTFE skates should
offer a smooth clean Glide
so far
not everyone agrees the most feet are
not up to par with other top tier Brands
but when it comes to the stock skates
they're still absolute dark and you
need to replace these another
controversial change is logitech's
decision to upgrade to 2K polling rates
rather than 4K many of their competitors
have already made the jump to 4K and
even 8K so it does feel a bit weird we
talked about the community's reaction to
that decision in our video about polling
rates last month if you want to check
that out later truthfully the arguably
best update to the super light 2 is that
it now uses USB type-c they certainly
took their sweet time but uh Hey better
late than never I guess so that's
basically everything new about the super
light too but does it actually feel
better well luckily Logitech were kind
enough to send Nile their new mouse so
that he could test it out and here's
what he thought and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
alright so first off I just want to say
thank you to Logitech for sending me the
mouse to review this video is not
sponsored by them so as always I'm just
here to give you my honest feedback on
the mess I've mostly been using it on
valorent and old school RuneScape for
the past few weeks and here's what
happened when I opened up the box it was
almost impossible to tell the difference
between the original super light and the
new one of course my OG super light is
magenta but in a purely visual sense the
only changes are the USBC port and the
direction of the pro super light text
it's no longer sideways when you turn
the mouse over the bottom skate also
points slightly outwards rather than
inwards now once I started moving the
mouse around on my soft Artisan zero my
initial impression was that the skates
are pretty bad I don't expect stock
skates to be amazing on any Mouse but
the super light 2s felt really muddy and
just too slow for me and since they
changed the skate design I can't just
put my extra set of core pads on the
mouse either which is pretty annoying I
don't know why they decided to change
the shape of the skates but moving on as
for the new switches a lot of people
have been complaining that they feel way
heavier than the original super light
but there seems to be a lot of variants
with each copy of this mouse mine really
didn't feel that much heavier and I
actually like the slightly more tactile
feel here's a quick sound comparison
Logitech says that the scroll wheel is
unchanged but I actually think it feels
better my original super light felt and
sounded kind of scratchy but the new one
is smooth and I can still feel each stop
nicely
as for the side buttons there's still
barely any post travel and the clicks
feel more tactile than the original
super light but even so they're still
not that great to set up the new mouse I
downloaded Logitech G Hub even though I
prefer using onboard memory manager then
I set the switches to Optical only set
my polling rate to 2K and adjusted my
DPI before testing out logitech's new
sensor calibration feature since I'd
been using pulsar's 4K x2h for about
three weeks before testing the super
light 2. I calibrated it using both mice
and g-hub actually told me that there
was a 17 DPI deviation so it applied
their correction to account for that DPI
deviation kinda scares me because two
mice both set to the same DPI can
actually feel different and that would
drive me nuts the goal of this
calibration is to help your old mouse
feel as similar as possible to your new
one that being said the x2h is roughly 6
grams lighter so unless you do this with
another 60 gram Mouse then it probably
won't feel the same no matter what you
do as Dimitri mentioned earlier here you
can actually set a separate DPI for the
X and Y axes but I didn't bother doing
this because I was kind of scared that
it would mess with my muscle memory once
everything was set up to my liking I
turned on onboard memory mode and
imported my profile just to avoid having
to use G Hub in the future then I hopped
into a game of valorent to see how the
super light 2 performs I used the
original G Pro and superlake quite a bit
over the past few years so I didn't have
to get used to the shape or anything
like that I felt pretty comfortable with
the mouse from the get-go but really
didn't enjoy the muddy skates so after a
few days I replaced them with some Super
Glide V2 dots and also tried the
included grips on Mouse 1 and 2. I'll
probably pick up some core pads or
something with a bit more control once
they become available and the included
grips were okay but I still prefer the
slightly grippier feel of Pulsar super
grip tip while testing the mouse I was
really trying to see if I could tell the
difference between logitech's 2K versus
the 4K that I've used on pulsar's x2h
and razer's Death Adder V3 Pro and
honestly I really couldn't to be fair
the super light always had very low
motion and click wait and see despite
the outdated Hardware so I'm not
surprised that the new mouse feels good
even on 2K pulling right the sensor was
always great I no longer have a zowie
with diac plus so maybe I would have
noticed a difference if I was still
using a faster monitor but it still felt
really good on my 240 hertz Acer and I
know a lot of people are upset that they
only managed to get the mouse down to 60
grams but personally I'm okay with
anything in the low 60s and there are
some basic mods that you can do to the
mouse if you really want to just know
that it might void your warranty plus
Logitech says that 60 grams is the
preferred weight for a lot of the pros
that they collaborated with when making
the mouse but where the super light 2
really shines is its battery life I
often found myself charging the x2h and
Death Adder every two or three days but
I can honestly go a full week without
charging the super light 2 which is
really nice between work and gaming my
mouse is on a lot so I was really
impressed with the super light 2's
efficiency overall I think it's a great
Great Mouse it's definitely not the
upgrade we were all hoping for but aside
from the skates I do enjoy most of the
changes that being said we can't just
ignore the fact that at 160 US Dollars
it has a very steep price tag and I
honestly just can't justify spending
that much money on this mouse if you
already own a super light then I don't
think you need to go out and get the
upgrade until there's some sort of price
drop which is unlikely to happen soon
since the mouse just came out I'll
probably just stick with my 4K Death
Adder and x2h for now and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about and there you have it the super
light 2 is easily the most hyped Mouse
release of the year but so far it has
been met with mixed reviews and we kind
of agree are the upgrades enough for you
to pick one up though well that's for
you to decide the thing is there's a lot
more competition now than there was a
couple of years ago in some ways the
super light 2 is still outclassed by a
lot of other mice and those mice cost a
fraction of the price Logitech has
dominated the peripheral space with both
of the G Pro and super light for a good
long while but with their newest release
it seems like now they are the ones with
some catching up to do
this is the Pulsar x2h you find it's big
enough for your hand so this is the
crazy thing Colton something about the
way that they've done the hump in the
back and the width there's like some
witchcraft involved but it just
fits